tout d'abord si vous venez d'acheter vos
vêtements de sports d'hiver
rassurez-vous la mode 74 dans ce domaine
sera assez semblable à celle de l'hiver
73 sur le plan coloris le jaune citron
le bleu électrique le coq de roche reste
les couleurs de base mais on note une
légère évolution vers des couleurs plus
sombres où je fonce et ouvert sap
quant aux lignes et aux formes elle joue
le bien-être la décontraction une
certaine ampleur fluides et souples
parfaitement adapté à la pratique du ski
c'est du moins l'avis d'une spécialiste
que nous avons rencontrés au salon
florence tu aurais je vais essayer un
petit peu tous les modèles
on a l'embarras du choix c'est bien
mathieu de bach
couleur par le fort
ce cas maintenant quand vous étiez dans
l'équipe de france ne contient ni forme
vous appréciez maintenant pouvoir mettre
un peu n'importe quel vêtement
ah oui c'est agréable mais l'enjeu
l'habiller enfin
j'ai pas besoin de trac soucier
l'esthétique la forme
points chauds de la mode 74 le mélange
des matières et des impressions que l'on
retrouve au rayon enfant rayon
particulièrement attrayant pour l'ex
championne olympique christine déranger
aujourd'hui mère de deux fillettes que
c'est dû trouver quelque chose qui soit
mignon mais surtout fonctionnel parce
que la montagne des enfants sont
toujours des souvent découvert ça c'est
difficile de garder bien habillé surtout
quand on invite des pays qui fut fait
assez froid et on penser que c'est
thomas des bien adapté on trouve pas mal
de choses joué d'autant plus que c'est
quand même ce qu'il faut là cette année
on fait pas mal de couleurs vives et je
trouve que c'est très joli surtout pour
des enfants quand un enfant est il faut
quand même lui mettre des couleurs à
seville presque tous les modèles
présentés au salon de grenoble sont
réalisés en îlots antiglisse les ans
indispensable pour évoluer sur les
pistes est apportée par le stretch le
confort enfin on le trouve dans les
modèles anti froid parmi lesquels comme
nous l'a confirmé la skieuse france aux
maquis la salopette et rennes
la mode est un petit peu ça ne pète ça
comporte pas mal
c'est très agréable et blouson qu'en
pensez vous je pense que c'est joli et
ça allonge la silhouette de
des dames et je pense que faire c'est
agréable avec la salopette pratique les
couleurs vives
c'est mieux sur la neige si jolie en
résumé donc en 1974 les baisses solaire
est les blues ont assorti au salopette
mais la mode est un éternel
recommencement
on signale déjà pour l'hiver 75 un
retour aux classiques fuseaux et à
l'ancienne parkas vestes longues
coulisses et à la taille mais
n'anticipons pas